i don't like that she says i can't trust
you i would not cheat on natalie
but i mean the last couple was i have
processed a lot of that yeah
i've done a lot of thinking and we have
done a lot of talking
there's been a lot of hard talking and
there's been good talks in there too as
well
me and now they're trying to work on
things the visa is
not ready so i guess that gives us time
right now to get it figured out
but what she did made me take a big step
back and be really really
kind of cautious
[Music]
hello baby hi
[Music]
i got some news
i've got my papers for my museum today
what did they say
you got your visa yes really
i got it
sorry
i feel happy excited
at the same time i don't know
[Music]
i did i i just was i wasn't prepared to
hear this right now
[Music]
when she said hey i got the visa and
come to the u.s
i had a ton of emotions in that moment
good and bad
we've both been looking forward to the
visa this entire time
but we have problems we have issues we
kind of put the visa on the back burner
[Music]
you